so what do you think about the
expansion not through the biology side
but through the bci the brain computer
interfaces
yeah you got a chance to check out the
neural link stuff it's super interesting
like like humans like like our thoughts
to manifest as action
you know like like as a kid you know
like shooting a rifle was super fun
driving a mini bike doing things and
then computer games i think
for a lot of kids became the thing where
they you know they can do what they want
they can fly a
plane they can do this they can do this
right but you have to
have this physical interaction now
imagine
you know you could just imagine stuff
and it happens
right like really richly
and interestingly like we kind of do
that when we dream like dream
dreams are funny because like if you
have some control or awareness in your
dreams
like it's very realistic looking or not
realistic
it depends on the dream but you can also
manipulate that
and you know what what's possible there
is is odd and the fact that nobody
understands it's hilarious but
um do you think it's possible to expand
that capability through computing
sure is there some interesting so from a
hardware designer perspective
is there do you think you'll present
totally new challenges in the kind of
hardware
required that like so this hardware
isn't
standalone computing well this just
never came with the brain so today
computer games are rendered by gpus
right right
so but you've seen the gans stuff yep
right
where trained neural networks render
realistic images but there's no pixels
no triangles no shaders
no light maps no nothing so the future
of
graphics is probably ai right yes
now that ai is heavily trained by lots
of real
data right so if you have an interface
with a
aai renderer right
so if you say render a cat it won't say
well how tall is the cat and how big
you know it'll render a cat and you
might say a little bigger a little
smaller you know
make it a tabby shorter hair you know
like you could tweak it
like the the amount of data you'll have
to
send to interact with a very powerful ai
renderer could be low but the question
is
for brain computer interfaces would need
to
render not onto a screen but render onto
the brain
and like directly so that there's a
bandwidth we could do it both ways i
mean our eyes are really good sensors
it could render onto a screen and
we could feel like we're participating
in it you know they're gonna
they're gonna have you know like the
oculus kind of stuff it's gonna be so
good when a projection is in your eyes
you think it's real
you know they're slowly solving those
problems
and i suspect when the renderer of that
information
into your head is also ai mediated
either they'll be able to give you the
cues that you know you really want for
depth and all kinds of stuff
like your your brain is probably faking
your your visual field right
like your eyes are twitching around but
you don't notice that occasionally they
blank you don't notice that
you know there's all kinds of things
like you think you see over here but you
don't really see there yeah it's all
fabricated
yeah so yeah peripheral vision is
fascinating
so if you have an ai renderer that's
trained to understand exactly how you
see
and the kind of things that enhance the
realism of the experience
could be super real actually
so i don't know what the limits that are
but
obviously if if we have a brain
interface that goes in
inside your you know visual cortex in a
better way than your eyes do
which is possible it's a lot neurons
yeah maybe that will be even
cooler
you